IT'S NOW TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
>> NOT ONLY IS COMIC-CON
HAPPENING THIS WEEK BUT IT'S
ALSO ROLLER CON WHERE THE
BEAUTIFUL BRUTES OF ROLLER DERBY
CONVERGE ON LAS VEGAS.
SINCE NOT ALL CONVENTIONS CAN BE
THIS COOL, TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS
LAME CONVENTION, EXAMPLES WOULD
BE:
HERPES-CON, OR GATHERING OF
THE SECOND BECKYS FROM ROSEANN.
60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK AND
GO.
>> YES, SARAH SHAEFER.
CON-CON, ALSO KNOWN AS PRISON.
>> YES, POINTS.
NICE. MARC.
>> NEUROTIC-CON, I HAVE A
TENT BE THERE, IT'S OKAY, NO,
IT'S NOT REALLY. IT'S NICE, IT'S
FINE.
>> POINTS. KYLE.
>> TOYOTA-THON.
(LAUGHTER)
>> POINTS.
>> WRATH OF KHAN-CON.
>> YES POINTS. I THINK YOU MEAN
WRATH OF KHAAAN!.
>> ANOTHER ONE.
>> YES.
>> CHAKA KHAN
>> YES, POINTS. PERFECT. SARAH
SHAEFER.
>> GATHERING OF THE
RUFFALOS.
IT'S A MARK RUFFALO
IMPERSONATORS GATHER.
>> POINTS. POINTS. KYLE.
>> STAR WARS, GIVE IT A
RESTFEST.
>> I WILL GIVE YOU POINTS
ALTHOUGH I OPPOSE THE CONCEPT.
MARC.
>> CON ON THE COBB
>> POINTS, YES, I LOVE IT,
SARAH SCHAEFER.
>> MENOPAUSE-CON.
LAME -- YOU WANTED LAME.
>> THAT WOULD BE A BAD ONE.
>> I GAVE YOU LAME.
>> POINTS. KYLE.
>> INTERNATIONAL MR. PLETHER
OF VEGAN BONDISH FESTIVAL.
(APPLAUSE)
>> POINTS.